you wanted to know why i brought you
here
there's a hidey hole where i'm standing
open it
empty it
[Applause]
these yours they were belong to you now
huh huh 50 years back
mexican conflict when i was a young piss
brain like you i enlisted with a corp
army
was in mexico when i realized that no
matter the conflict
corpse always win ordinary people always
lose so that the truth you decided to
reveal in song
well deserted first wound up here locked
in this
room laid in bed staring at the ceiling
fan for a good month
i wouldn't mind lying down right now
watching a fan till the end of time it's
why i brought you here
wasting days weeks that's the step i
want you to skip
why are you giving me these imagine
we're deployed together
fighting in a war side by side
would you take a bullet for me
i would yeah
tags belong to a man who sacrificed his
life for mine in mexico
been thinking about our predicament
wanna be clear i will do you no wrong
when the time comes it'll be my life for
yours i'll agree to get white
tags are proof of my promise
so you ready i
i do the same for you yeah
thanks
you seriously considering hanukkah's
offer
got a better idea not yet
but i got a request well
adam smasher [ __ ] who got the better
of me
whatever happens to me i want him zero
gone tossed into the wind as
mulch
right understood
and i want rogue to be there with you
it's important to me and it's just as
important for her
so i gotta tell rogue everything
think i'd better do that handle it
personally
you'll drop the pills from misty and
i'll steer the ship for a bit
i'm not at all excited about this plan
realize that right
just gonna have a quick chat with rogue
about smasher
then i'm out i promise
need to know exactly what you plan to do
i'll tell rogue the truth see if she's
willing to help
hey satan kicked me out of hell thought
i'd swing by
all i gotta do is mention smasher serve
him up on a platter
muse over the old days easy
fine i'll do this for you
appreciate it thanks take me to the
afterlife
promise you won't regret this feeling
better
it should get going still feel a sharp
something near your heart
doubt that's ever going away
the hotel pissed to sophia that right
good place to die just not today